thank you I always love it when I get my
first ward draws applause and I think
it's all about how long you pause for
afterward and just make people feel
awkward as a presentation trick for you
so working at Microsoft and being
focused mainly on Python I was a Python
developer before working at Microsoft I
have a number of embarrassing stories I
I come out to these conferences and i'm
known as the windows guy that that's
fine i'll accept that but I go back to
Microsoft and there i'm known as the
python guy which means when python stuff
happens i get to hear about it so and
and you know microsoft's filled with a
lot of very smart people very you know
they know their computer systems well
and and so it's a little embarrassing to
have you know directors of development
hopping on IM late at night just
messaging me saying i tried to pip
install numpy and it didn't work how do
i fix it or to go into a meeting with
someone who's there's about a thousand
levels of hierarchy this guy was
probably three levels down from CEO
saying he right my kids are learning
python i had to spend two hours with
them getting it set up on their machine
last night oh ouch and then every now
and then there's other teams at the
company that want to use python and you
microsoft is a window shop big surprise
but some teams go oh we want to use
python we're on everything on linux
because it works better that makes me
sad so why is windows so broken and what
is the way to fix it how do you deal
with that how do you get around it but
of course the other question is it's
obvious why I do but why should you care
about Windows why would anyone who's not
otherwise forced into it care about
windows at all and there's a couple of
reasons that I want to call out it comes
down to users though this is download
starts just rough approximation from the
month of July from python org
they don't compare very well that top
bar is the mac OS downloads mac OS comes
with python people get it from other
places that number doesn't matter next
one is the source downloads most people
can get the sauce from elsewhere it
doesn't count for much but that last bar
is downloads for Windows Python dog is
the main place people get Python for
Windows and that number is more than 4
million in one month over a year that's
40 50 million downloads of Python for
windows every year annually that's a lot
of people getting and using Python
windows has some of the best tools for
using Python this is just a sample of
the Ides that are available some of
these are available on other platforms
as well but for users who get into the
IDE space or get into the advanced tools
the advanced debuggers the ones that let
you step through C code and Python code
the ones that let you generate a whole
lot of stuff and build it together
really quickly get attached to their 80s
visual studio is obviously the one that
I work on people switch to Windows just
so they can use visual studio and that's
why python has to run on windows and a
lot of people do real work on it we took
a survey a couple of years back not from
the Microsoft pool of people that we'd
talk to we went to other sources to find
data scientists and say what are you
using what are you running on that
biggest father is the people who are
doing that development work on Windows
the barbel load is the people who end up
deploying to windows as their final
target for their code there are that
many reasons why you need to care about
windows your code no matter unless it's
completely in-house is eventually going
to be running on Windows somewhere you
need to be aware of it you need to be
ready for it so there are three problems
three big problems which all come out of
those embarrassing stories I told
earlier packages are hard to install is
the first one we all know this red
everyone knows the packages don't
install properly on windows and
obviously it's because there's no
compiler right windows is client
operating system first even a server
operating system but it's not really a
developer first operating system doesn't
come with the compiler pre-install
doesn't come with a like a complete dev
tool chain by default which means of the
hundreds of millions of users who have
windows also hundreds of millions of
them don't have a compiler handy but
that's not the only problem it's
actually the culture if you compare
Windows to Linux there's a very big
culture difference as far as obtaining
and using software linux and and the
ones prey to that are what i would call
developer first developers are the first
target of that operating system they're
going to have a compiler they're going
to have a tool chain they're going to
need it and the source and the tools and
the programs on those platforms are
built around that idea that whatever
you're giving to someone to run on their
machine they will be able to compile it
and they will probably need to compile
it because they've compiled something
else themselves as well windows has a
different culture to that and always has
it's a binary operating system it's a
non developer first operating system
where people want to grab precompiled
executables and just start running them
it's a totally different culture it
means you don't ship sources everywhere
it means closed-source software as
possible open source software is
somewhat less relevant to a lot of mere
users of the software because they're
not interested in the source they don't
need it for anything they want your
executable files they want something
that they can just double click and run
and actually make use of it what this
means for Python packages is when the
ecosystem for Python packages builds up
around shipping source code particularly
for extension modules that doesn't fit
the culture on Windows there's a
mismatch there and you have all these
windows developers ending up with sauce
which may make perfect sense on Linux
and it doesn't make any sense at all for
the windows users but once you get past
not having the compiler there are more
issues you have source code maybe
assuming your user on Windows has the
compiler your code may have other
dependencies it depends on other source
files does the user have those maybe
they do they probably don't most Windows
users don't have a big collection of
source for other third-party libraries
on their machine so you need to worry
about that
distributing software by sauce on
Windows even once the compiler is there
you may have binary dependencies things
that your code assumes are available as
part of the operating system that simply
are not there on Windows doesn't matter
whether that user has the compiler or
not people like to get stuck at that
point there's no compiler it's all
broken having a compiler will fix it all
not if your code assumes that you can
fork not if your code assumes that you
have Libya V naught if your code assumes
that everything behaves exactly the way
that it does inside the Linux kernel and
then there's a BAS even if you have a
built equivalent for that even if you
get past the source and binary
dependencies there will be mismatches
compilers generate different code
calling conventions differ the actual
interface at the binary level is going
to be different and this these three
things combined once you get past the
compilers lead to the problem of
packaging not working well on Windows
people can't install extension modules
can't use your code so here's the good
news the compilers are easy to get now
over the last two or three years we've
made a lot of effort within Microsoft to
get the compilers needed out there I'll
have links at the end but you can now
get the right compiler to build
extension modules for Python 27 which
includes 26 and 33 32 if you really want
you can easily get the compiler for 35
onwards 33 and 34 is two extra steps on
top of that but we have info on how to
do it it's not a single click but the
compilers are no longer the blocking
step if at the worst case you can tell
your users get the compiler then you can
install my package but that's a worst
case because it turns out that wheels
are a really good culture fit if you're
not familiar with wheels these are the
packaging format for Python packages
that include all of the bill see
extensions already so one person
hopefully someone on the development
team has the compiler has the source
dependencies has the binary dependencies
builds the package on
was it into a wheel marks it as this is
Windows version and again the platform
market for Windows is either 32-bit or
64-bit there's no other variants to
worry about there are literally two
platforms and that will work windows tip
well windows XP or Windows Vista up to
the latest versions so you've only got
to do it twice for two windows platforms
and then every single one of your users
can pip install your package get the
wheel and be up and going without
needing a compiler without needing a
tool chain I can see some careful faces
who probably have packages that have
other dependencies that they don't know
how to ship in a wheel you just need to
provide more instructions for your users
because you're doing something
complicated I'm afraid packages that
have simple C extensions accelerators
along those lines that don't have extra
third party dependencies have a real
easy time shipping in wheels continuous
integration sorry go ahead
yes so so the question is our wheels the
way to bridge the culture gap yes they
are if you have wheels built for windows
for your package you've bridged that gap
maybe there's a few more setup
instructions for users but those
instructions probably don't require
becoming a developer continuous
integration systems are catching up at
their visual studio team services
there's a few other will let you build
for free with some throttled thing on
Windows to produce those wheels you
don't have to even have your own install
of windows to make these builds you can
do it all through continuous integration
these days and again you only need one
instance to make all of the different
targets for windows because on a 64-bit
machine you can make the 32-bit package
or the 64-bit package and of course
distributions are available as a user
when you need just all of the packages
ready to go a distribution like anaconda
like canopy like wind python like Python
XY someone has gone and done all the
work someone has built all of the
packages so as a data scientist who
simply wants to use Python with all of
its packages and numpy and sigh pay and
scikit-learn and just have them work
those districts are often the way to go
if you're building up a web app from
minimal stack and pulling in just the
pieces you need may not be the best
starting point they will work for that
with a bit more complicated effort but
it is certainly a valid option and it's
what we generally recommend to users now
if you just want to be using Python with
all these packages get anaconda install
that use that and this came out today
for those who don't know glyph he
maintains well helps maintain twisted
which is one of the most complicated
python packages out there very
high-performance networking stack and he
is announcing python packaging is good
now
which people can laugh about and he
expects them to if you go read the blog
but over the last considering that the
path the history of Python packaging
extends for over ten years over the last
two or three years with wheels with
continuous integration systems with
newer versions of PIP with better
versions of setuptools Python packaging
is actually in a very good place if you
want to compare it to other languages
that were invented 10 20 years after
Python and say that they have better
packaging built in from the start
consider that Python had already made
the mistakes that may those languages
better but pythons coming background and
catching up a simple setup type a file
will work for the vast majority of
extensions these days did you have a
question ok so that's packaging it's not
that bad it's not that bad and the way
to fix it is wheels the next problem
Python is hard to install hard to launch
and insecure most people aren't even
familiar with the third one but that is
the case and some people have widely
recognized that installing Python on
Windows is actually a big security hole
to install Python on Windows you've got
to be an administrator now for
developers this is not such a big deal
you're the only one on your machine you
have full control over it dialog pops up
saying do you really want to install
this and you say yep okay and go ahead
and it's fine now you've got Python
installed but for a huge majority of
users especially on windows which
includes students which includes people
in lockdown corporate environments even
some research institutions I'm aware of
do not have administrator access to
their own machine you can't install
Python on those machines and that's a
serious issue that's seriously cutting
out users of Python on Windows it
installs and system directories it's
actually going to put files in a system
location where the system is meant to
have their files it's going right
alongside colonel
drivers on the file system which is
really interesting idea and a whole lot
of security auditing software is going
to say hey what are you doing please
don't do that this is not your directory
going store somewhere else the Windows
registry disliked by a lot of people who
would rather just have you know one
central configuration file which I would
argue is the registry but but if you
don't use it properly then you'll have
collisions Python and especially older
versions of other distros are all going
to try and write the same registry keys
that causes collisions that causes
problems because they're going to look
for their own settings information in a
place where someone else has written it
it's bad even the 32-bit and 64-bit
version of Python would overwrite each
other's registry settings and so you
couldn't have 32-bit and 64-bit at the
same time on the same machine which is a
real problem messy path everyone likes
having Python on their path so you can
just go to the terminal and type Python
I personally don't and on Windows this
is actually a bigger issue than you may
think the path variable on Windows is
not intended for your convenience at the
console it's intended for the operating
system to find dynamically linked loaded
libraries which is why the system
directory is first on that list and if
you put another directory before the
system directory you're now going to
load dynamically linked dll's from your
directory instead of the system
directory that's going to break a whole
lot of stuff it's it's messy there's
also no central way of prioritizing
items in this list apart from user
intervention manually manually editing
last installed version of Python added
to the path will be the one that you use
even if it's an older version and it's
insecure default location for the
install is right in your root directory
which by default gets permissions has
right permissions for every single user
on that system so even if you install it
as an administrator if someone logs on
to that machine as a guest someone
remotes into that machine from the
network
someone somehow gets onto your machine
they can go and edit your Python files
including the standard library including
your site customized they can put code
in that that is going to run the next
time you use Python without you knowing
it this is a really big issue especially
in multiuser environments again
developers not always in these
environments corporate users often in
these environments so spoiler this is
the good news that was all pay from 27
do you like a reason to upgrade to 35 so
Python 35 is when I took over the
Installer maintenance of C Python first
thing I did was go in and made a whole
lot of fixes so Python 35 on Windows you
can install without being an
administrator one little caveat to that
is if you're operating system is not
fully up to date you've got to update it
bring it up to date and then you can
store without being admin you may have
to be an admin to install the updates
one little caveat there anyone who's on
Windows 10 which I think you have to pay
for now sorry already has all the
updates you need so everyone on the
latest version of Windows can install
without being admin everything goes in
the install directory there's absolutely
no point to go dropping Python into the
system directory so we stopped there's
no more registry collisions so the first
thing that I changed for 35 was to get
the 32-bit registry separate from the
64-bit no matter how you install it so
that collision is gone the next thing
was pep 514 which you can go and look up
if you're really interested in this this
is a registry format for all the distros
to be able to have their own space to
port registry settings so it means that
if you install Python 35 and you install
the latest version of anaconda and you
install the latest version of let's
imagine another destroy that's actually
implemented this already they're not
going to stomp on each other they're not
going to over at each other's entries
you'll have three distinct pythons there
they can all be located
this is a big step forward as far as not
destroying users systems by installing
Python too many times the P way launcher
PAP 397 it's been around for a couple of
versions but this is how you deal with
paths on Windows the PA lon cho installs
into a separate location that does go on
path the idea is that python dot exe
does not go on path and you use pyx see
instead what this will do is scrape all
of those registry entries look in
certain environment variables looking a
few configuration files and map out all
the versions of Python you have on your
machine and will either pick the latest
version pick the version that you've
told it as the default or it will look
in your script file for a shebang line
including a unique style shebang line
find the matching version of Python on
Windows and run with that which means if
you have a script that should run on
paths and three on UNIX and Python 3 on
Windows you can put shebang user bin
Python 3 run it with a py launch run
windows and it'll run with Python 3 and
finally secure install directory which
is often pointed out is a much longer
directory name than it used to be with
the py launcher that shouldn't matter
but the change their means that if you
install for all users on the machine if
an administrator installs for all users
it will go in program files nobody can
modify program files unless they're an
administrator if you installed just for
yourself it goes in your user directory
no one can modify that except for you
which means you don't have to worry
about people dropping extra files into
your python install anymore
and the third problem in inverted quotes
isn't that guy cute
it might be deliberately scary yeah
Python just works better on Linux I mean
peyton has always had a reputation for
working well cross-platform and it's
incredibly well deserved Python has
always worked really well on Windows
despite the fact that I don't think
there's ever been more than three people
actively trying to maintain or develop
Python for windows there's about 20 core
developers at the moment 20 30 core
contributors three of the active ones
are listed as Windows experts all the
rest never touch windows some of them
are quite proud of that others
acknowledge that it's not such a good
thing that they don't touch windows but
they don't have the time to pick it up
and learn it but despite that pythons
always been good on Windows but better
on Linux and this is a problem because
it gives people a reason to simply say I
will ignore Windows completely and focus
on the platform that it's clearly
designed for and the reasons that it
doesn't quite match the compilers are
not equivalent on Linux it's generally
built with GCC it has claimed support if
you want to try and do that i believe on
mac OS can be it's not currently built
with clang for the official releases but
i think some of the ports that are
available are built with clang on
windows we build with the platform
native compiler toolchain microsoft
visual c++ which has some slightly
different behavior between like from
other compilers if you build python with
the Microsoft tool chain and want to
build an extension with GCC they're not
going to be compatible directly system
calls are not universal there are things
that you can simply do on a linux
operating system that don't exist on
Windows there are things you can do on
windows that don't exist on Linux and
that means that you have some different
functionality if you're writing code
that absolutely depends on one of those
and won't work on the other you've cut
out a big chunk of potential customers
regardless of which direction you go if
you rely entirely on the authentication
mechanisms that are available on Linux
then
not going to work on Windows if you rely
entirely on some of the the net security
stuff that's on Windows it's not going
to work on linux Python tries to bridge
the gap as much as possible but has to
make compromises and as a result Linux
tends to win those because of the
greater bulk of developers contributing
that but as we saw earlier a lot of
Python developers or data scientists are
developing on Windows and deploying to
Linux this needs confidence you can't
spend your time developing on one
platform and hope to deploy it to
another and have nothing change you need
to know that nothing's going to change
and as a result when people are forced
or required to deploy to Linux they end
up developing on Linux as well so that
they can be assured that everything that
they write is going to behave the same
in development as it does in test as it
doesn't production which ends up being a
problem for windows because there are
less people deploying to Windows despite
the earlier graphic as a whole across a
Python community there are there are far
more Python programs deployed to Linux
than there are two windows across the
span of things so the improvements here
the things that are already better and
going to get better into the future
Python 3.5 uses a modern compiler it has
almost all c99 support it has all of the
header files that kept breaking stuff on
earlier versions I spent an hour at one
sprint trying to get ffmpeg to build on
the old compiler and it was never going
to happen but on the latest up-to-date
visual c++ it compiles just fine and
that's going to continue into the future
it's been set up this time so that you
can keep using the most up-to-date
compiler against Python 35 onwards and
have the availability of the latest
tools there you're not locked into an
old compiler you're not locked into an
incompatible compiler by virtue of what
Python was built with there are good
libraries out there to hide the platform
I mentioned twisted earlier that is a
great way to simply ignore what's going
on under the hood and it will give you
the most performant
networking on windows and the most
performant networking on Linux despite
them being implemented differently
because that's what the good libraries
are for other libraries will equally
layer over the sis calls that are
involved and give you a nice clean API
to work from while having libraries that
are going to do the switching for the
platform and the big one this is new so
i'm going to show you this one all right
what happens next what happens next if i
hit enter who thinks forget an error
message on a lot of machines you'll get
an error message this so this is not
cygwin this is not any layer well it's
not any user mode layer that you may
have seen before it's not men GW this is
a complete linux distribution to prove
it i will show you that it does in fact
have Python installed and it is an old
version this is not saying that
Microsoft has put together as much as
enabled this is a full Ubuntu
distribution installed running on
Windows you can see I'm still within the
same command prompt they haven't jumped
out to anything at all and no matter who
you ask it's its proper Linux running on
Windows if you want to develop if you
need to verify your code on Linux but
want to be developing with those awesome
tools i showed earlier this is the way
you can do it this is the way to
validate code running on Linux without
having to switch to another machine
without having to deal with ssh and all
the interesting behaviors of some of the
clients some various platforms this is
local linux it is in fact it even has
full ntfs access to my current drive
including right mood which i don't know
who we paid to do that but we made that
work
so that's available now this is to get
this I will have a link up in a sec but
this is the latest update for Windows 10
which is available now can you edit this
a fast one for IE have not tried let's
chat afterwards I hope not ok I have
links coming up there cameras ready
because i'm going to leave it on this
last slide so that you can get you can
find all of this stuff later Windows has
a reputation for being broken with
Python it is not well deserved anymore
few years ago it was absolutely well
deserved packaging was a mess
installation was a mess security was a
mess compatibility was a mess now if
python is still a mess on windows for
you part of the problem is that you're
still using 27 part of the reason is
you're not using one of the distros and
includes 27 that have improved a number
of these things but the future of Python
on Windows is Python 35 and onwards is
looking very Brad much more stable much
more secure much more compatible and
much more well supported from all
directions industry and community thank
you for coming a name Steve dower happy
to take questions
so the question is is Linux for Windows
a is it performant it's essentially is
it meant for production or is it meant
for testing at the moment it's very much
meant for testing performance wise I
there are certainly some performance
bench benchmarks online quite a few
people have gone in and done it the one
that the team behind it mentioned to me
was what were they compiling they
compiled something with GCC and it was
like a 1.3 times slow down compared to
being on a native box so it's very close
to having linux on a native box the way
that works like I say it's not a user
mode cham it's a kernel mode shim every
time that Linux makes a cyst call that
gets intercepted transformed into a
Windows kernel call and is fulfilled by
the windows kernel but everything every
binary is an elf binary there's been no
modifications that Ubuntu is the same
abun to that you would get if you
installed it from the same distro on a
different machine the only difference is
the colonel internally has been swapped
out for mapping to the windows kernel
yes so the difference between a compiler
and a compiler for python is absolutely
nothing these links are version numbered
with the Python version so VC Python 27
is the compiler for Python 27 these VC
Python 35 is the compiler 435 the
version numbers of the compilers are
different so internally that the first
one is version 9 the other one is
version 14 if you don't know what that
means it's not very helpful so I made
links that have the Python version
number in there but in fact the 14 to
seven was a special release for Python
27 so that one's labeled for Python 27
because it's an old deprecated compiler
that we want to get rid of but everyone
still needs it so we got it out there
specifically for Python developers yes
do it so yeah so I'm a little concerned
do I think that people are going to like
package developers are going to tell
their users i'll just use linux on
windows so i don't have to build my
package I suspect there'll be some of
that and this may be the reason that
it's not being that we're actively not
telling people hey go use this in
production right now I suspect that it's
there's going to be some
incompatibilities there's going to be
some vague differences there that are
still that you know we're probably down
2.1 percent incompatible as opposed to
ninety percent incompatible but I don't
know that until it like until those
around out I don't think people will be
completely confident running that in
production yet and so there's still
going to be a need for people locked
into Windows Server who are not able to
use the containerization support to run
a linux container in there yet who are
still going to want to be deploying on
Windows natively there's also a number
of packages that people want to use and
again I get questions about these all
the time the people want to be using on
their clients and so I think there's
always going to be a demand for packages
on Windows what we really hope that this
that the Linux support will enable is
people will be able to have so rather
than being in an alternative operating
system where maybe you have your ninety
percent full POSIX compatibility and a
lot of edge cases they can be on Windows
and have close to one hundred percent
POSIX compatibility through this option
it's going to be more integrated over
time and will be we hope a very good
development environment combining and
really blurring the lines between the
windows part of the OS and the Linux
part of the OS but we certainly hope
that for developers it will enable
living on windows for a lot of the time
and being able to run the code on Linux
without leaving that OS at all
do I see the linux on windows being the
default way to install Python I don't
think it will but I am still not sure
yet I'm looking for really good
suggestions on how to make the pipe the
windows version of Python so much better
than the Linux one that people want to
use it anyway and I have a few ideas on
how on things that we can do with Python
on windows to make it so much better on
Windows that if you are using windows
you'll want to stay there but again
certainly for some people it will become
the alternative and some people will
switch to it that's great both the
number I developers are in the room Oh
sigh hi sorry
Wow works on Windows great where's that
justjust for the video can i get you to
repeat the question please is Microsoft
gonna do something like prepaid compiled
packages on Windows that's going to get
snipped out and sent up my management
chain yeah certainly there's a lot of
interest in in fully built distributions
of life of Python for windows including
a lot of packages there's definite value
in that certainly the the last that I
heard from the guys that continuum the
guys that n thought is they ship many
many many more copies for Windows and
they do for other platforms and I would
assume that that's still the case there
is so to get to this series of questions
Fortran compiler is probably unlikely to
come from us as I understand from
chatting with a lot of the non pay guys
and a lot of the soap a guys the biggest
concern with the best available compiler
on windows right now which is the Intel
one would likely also be a concern if
Microsoft did one because I can't see us
releasing it in a GPL compatible way
because we tend not to do that so that's
unlikely to actually solve the problem
Intel's one I understand is difficult to
well is not a single click download to
get hold of and that again this is
probably a case where the main reason
people need the Fortran compiler is for
developing the fortran code
simultaneously I also hear that the
reason we don't just deprecated the
fortran code and replace it with c code
is because it son maintainable so given
those two
so I've been told that the two choices
are either for lip for high performance
linear algebra is either inline assembly
or fortran code i would argue that out
of line assembly is also an option and
that's totally supported by all the
compilers that you like including the
assembler so I I would disagree but
that's a separate conversation to have
that is not one of the main floors with
Windows right now and in fact I think
this is something where the the Linux
command line will make a big difference
for people who want to develop that and
are on windows because as I've said in
previous discussions with people a lot
of this is very platform agnostic
especially the the numpy and scifi side
of things so developing that code and
and tuning it on Linux is not going to
hurt significantly when you port it to
Windows compared to something like say
twisted where the entire thing is native
API calls and you can't validate that on
Linux and expect it to just work the
same on Windows
yeah so essentially could could windows
a ship a blast library and and yes yes
it could those libraries are a very big
investment and for Microsoft to go off
and invest in that is certainly a
business decision that's outside of MAPE
my pay grade as far as allocating
resources and saying let's do this and
give it away for free that's not our
business model as you may be aware
Microsoft makes money from selling
software you know as opposed to
companies they give you software and
also adds though I think we're getting
into that as well because it's lucrative
it means we can give you more software
so yeah py py pronounced pie pie as
opposed to as opposed to PI PA that does
a factor and I mean it certainly does
it's not currently as well support on
windows as other platforms we have not
been hearing from from the people we
interact with a huge demand for it is
really what it comes down to there's
certainly a few very keen people who
would love it to be fully supported on
Windows but for the people that are
coming to us and saying we have huge
bags of money in our back pocket we
really want pie pay support I they just
aren't doing that
I actually have very little interaction
with pi PI development team from either
of my my hats either at Microsoft or C
Python so I know I can't comment on
where pi PI is at these days so
ironpython I am a little more familiar
with because I'm still on the mailing
list for the Hat Microsoft obviously got
rid of own path and many years ago and
it became a community project that's
been led by a very busy person working
in Amazon he has recently passed on
leadership of ironpython to some other
people who claim to have more time so
expect more development there I believe
they're getting another alpha ready and
looking at adding Python 3 support or
finishing their Python 3 support very
soon which I believe is going to be 34
compatible possibly only 35 I'm not sure
exactly what they're targeting there but
ironpython development is back on and it
certainly still gets used I'm keep
running into people who are genuinely
using ironpython in production
frequently depending upon it it's far
from dead it's not the most supported
most active distribution of pie pan out
there but again considering the
ecosystem of Python distributions other
than CPA or Python implementations other
than C Python it's not doing too bad
so I have some interaction with visual
studio so the questions about Visual
Studio code where where is that out
where is it going as far as Python
support there's a great community
extension which has largely borrowed
from the support we wrote for visual
studio hour and that works great by all
accounts and so we're you know actively
telling people go get this extension we
are looking to you know contribute into
that and enhance a few things based on
our experience with visual studio so
over time I'd expect to see intellisense
get better debugging get better and
hopefully some more interactive mode
show up in Visual Studio code as for
other aspects of vs code I'm not part of
the core development team on that so I
don't know what their future plans are
but it is the general plan is for it to
be very extensible so if you can't
currently get an extension to change
source control provider or change the
target for your source control I would
assume that something will be coming so
you know will be available in that sense
there's no other questions I will be
around for the next couple of hours feel
free to come and chat otherwise enjoy
your lunch thank you